ultimately the right to free speech is
the right to be an [ __ ] and what
makes this country great [ __ ] threat
to free speech is the government
government the tendency to want to
create a government agency and
government supervisors that tendency
seems to be very great right now and
that's the biggest threat the greatest
threat to free speech is any person or
any entity who thinks that their idea is
more powerful and more important than
yours and tries to take it from you by
force the belief that civil discourse
can be made better by government
controlling things
the political class does not like to
have political speech protected because
they don't like criticism and they don't
like being told what a bunch of
jackasses they actually are it's
well-intentioned people on the left and
the right who are more or less on both
sides who have strong feelings for what
is right and who wanna our own good
interest impose it on us the two
political parties both of them have
politically correct sensibilities about
them the media because they never
usually accurately report exactly what
you say they put their own spin they put
their own spin on the facts even until
presented to another media outlet and to
let them put their own spin and
eventually you get about 50% of the
truth I've always said it was political
correctness because if you can't speak
openly and freely without being accused
in a reactionary manner as being a
fascist or a racist or sexist or a
homophobe or an anti Muslim what it does
is it chills free speech idiocy
narrowness provincialism in any attempts
at curbing the speech on the internet
all the
who are freaking out about the greatest
freak it's free expression tool in the
last 500 years the internet people think
it lowers the level of discourse it
doesn't it just lets you know the level
of discourse net neutrality I think this
is a huge threat to anyone who wants to
be able to say what they want
probably apathy on the part of the
public who is probably not either
educated enough or insufficiently
interested in public policy to me it's
it's young people not fully
understanding the history of this
country and it the history the First
Amendment some extent misuse of those
freedoms for both malicious partial
truth purposes
I think the biggest artists pre
expression is the war on terror it is
the concept of terrorism and the way it
is propagandized by governments around
the world you say give me liberty and
give me death but the minute the death
approaches we are willing to sell out
Liberty down the river and take our
chances with whatever happens to come
after it last question is her enemies
too far then this sort of fascism Adams
in free speech yeah most of the stuff on
vh1